so
uh
the first one is not our
manipulation i'm not doing this
the first line is absorb
and then
right back in just like this
doesn't matter where my hands are
because i can't really try to manipulate
the arm
i just have them in open end triangles
here's where i step and now you can see
the grip is
weak that's when you deal with the grip
so you're not going here
and trying to turn this
have a strong anchored elbow
i'm not gonna be able to do it and
you're gonna punch me in the face you
see
so
off
right
okay and then the grip is weakened
then you finally
so absorb
here
[Music]
so inside the keyhole rituals there's a
strategy
okay
and the strategy is
uh first control the body okay
um do not control
for example the extremity to control the
body
control the body and then you get the
extremity okay
so most of your
uh
your pins
are going to go
center
elbow wrist
that's your order of operation in terms
of what are you controlling okay so for
example you know he said don't go wrist
don't go wrist that's last you see
you're gonna punch do you get it
also
you don't want to uh just try to hit
because a lot she would be anchoring and
taking my posture you see and this isn't
going to happen the impact that i think
it's going to have because you're
checking me out and you're striking at
the same time you get it so inside your
ritual
as you come in i'm not there
you see that okay and then i deal with
this boom one you see not here
okay it goes into the body first
coming in
into the body okay now the next
turn
the next order of operation
is the elbow
not the wrist
it goes elbow elbow you see
the wrist is
last
so just as i wouldn't go here first
i
go body first boom
i don't go here this second
i go body first
elbow and wrist
last
got it so i exaggerated that gap so you
can feel that
my hand would be there but i wouldn't
pull it off the elbow
compromises the wrist
more and my hand is there to catch it
okay
let's go
okay oh
coq and ikea are engines they're engines
like anything else they just work
through internal mechanisms not external
mechanisms okay and they work with
energy and they don't work with fulcrums
and levels okay
but it's still an engine so there's
always a work output
ceiling do you get it it doesn't go for
forever all right do you understand that
uh a lot of it has to do like any engine
man if you don't have good bolts
the bolts are going to come out you
guess it has to do for example with the
quality of your organization
okay
so uh how how how much stress your
organization can take has a lot to do
with how much energy you can absorb and
bounce back off the ground okay so if i
have weak corners which you've all are
struggling with or have struggled with
energy goes out the corner and you can't
do it you see but so there's always a
ceiling though on all of this but you
combine it with
your external movements do you
understand so you can't decrease how
much energy the person is putting into
you
uh so for example when i go here that's
going to be a lot of energy
do you see that because i i'm
within the power stroke of his whoa
you see that but if i if i have good
cool cue
it'll it'll work but of course it can
get to
a ceiling that is higher than my work
output ceiling do you understand so when
you feel what you're feeling for is that
spot here do you see that okay
and with that
i still have my kazushi pattern
he's going this way
because it takes more energy
to go back
so we want to start him
spiraling you see that
so i go to where he's barely on
and
whoo
into the front inward
do you get that okay so that's just like
he killed so each uncut
so it doesn't change here
[Music]
not here
that's a lot if you can do it you can do
it but go around
until shhh
[Music]
i understand
you